hey if you have a moment check out our
online store at anime out Broadcom we
have exclusive designs created by pro
manga artist Kazuma including esken or
praise the Sun meliodas feel the wrath
and for a limited time all transiting
shaggy one-shotting Thanos because yes
that's a thing all the proceeds directly
support more content on this channel so
check it out link in the description
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the demon king the
one character who is very likely to turn
out to be the final boss in the entire
seven deadly sins series recent events
in the manga have put the ruler of the
demon clan in the forefront and we now
know that he has been formulating a
master plan that has been thousands of
years in the making a plan that could
bring about the violent death of many if
not all of our favorite seven deadly
sins characters in this video I will be
explaining the demon Kings master plan
and how it is likely to affect the story
going forward and I'm really looking
forward to not only the next chapter but
also to seeing what all of you guys
thought about the story so far and what
you think is going to happen next and
with that in mind I have a quick
announcement to celebrate chapter 300 of
the seven deadly sins manga we will be
hosting a live 7 Deadly Sins discussion
and Q&A on our twitch channel twitch.tv
slash anime uproar on Wednesday February
13th at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
that is ESD we will be live streaming on
Twitch we will be discussing all of the
crazy twists and turns of the manga and
we'll be taking your questions and
feedback live in the chat if we get a
big response for this stream we might
continue hosting them every week as the
new chapters come out so if that's
something you want to be a part of
please follow us on Twitch link in the
description and of course if you enjoyed
the seven deadly sins content on this
channel you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell warning this video
will be examining all the information
that we have so far including
information from the latest chapters of
the manga so if you're not caught up
please remember that there are spoilers
ahead proceed with caution in a previous
video I talked about the huge mystery
from the last chapter which is why when
meliodas
emerged from the cocoon after apparently
absorbing all ten of the commandments he
clearly aged instead of looking like his
normal child herself Mellie Otis now
looks like an adult version of itself
and in fact he seems to closely resemble
both my L and his old wanted poster in
that previous video I mentioned that
meliodas might have aged because after
absorbing the commandments he was able
to finally break the curse of
immortality that the demon king had
placed on him since meliodas was cursed
to be immortal he probably stopped aging
completely but now that he has broken
the curse the 3,000 years since the last
holy war have finally caught up to him
Zell dress still looks younger because
he had been sealed inside the coffin of
eternal darkness so we can assume that
he did not age for those 3,000 years but
now that the curse is seemingly broken
malleolus was finally able to age
physically except in Chapter 300 of the
manga we learned something shocking
this new adult meliodas that emerged
from the cocoon was not actually Mellie
Otis at all I mean yes it is meliodas
physically but after absorbing the 10
commandments which contain half of the
demon King's own power
Mellie Otis's body was possessed by the
demon king
and so now meliodas has become a new
younger vessel which allows the demon
king to escape purgatory and manifest
physically in Britannia all this time
the demon king had made everyone think
that he wanted meliodas to succeed him
as the next demon king and even his own
sons eldress believed this to be true
the demon king was even critiqued by
other demons including zelgius because
he was willing to forgive meli Otis's
treachery during the last holy war and
still allow his eldest son to succeed
him as the next demon king
however the demon king had a completely
different master plan in mind all along
and the ten commandments that he created
appeared to have been a brilliant trap
that he set for meliodas we've known for
a long time now that at some point in
the past the demon king had split his
powers in half and then divided that one
half of his power into the ten
commandments this ensured that no one
person could ever become powerful enough
to challenge him as it happened before
when the original demon tried to
overthrow the demon king and throughout
the past few arcs in the story meliodas
has had one clear goal a goal for which
he was willing to abandon the seven
deadly sins and everything he cared
about refusing to accept that Elizabeth
was going to
I yet again right in front of his eyes
as a result of the curse meliodas
decided that the only solution was to
absorb all 10 commandments which would
make him powerful enough to challenge
the demon king and become the next demon
king himself and then he would finally
have enough power to break Elizabeth's
curse once and for all
Zell drous decided to go along with this
plan because meliodas had promised that
when he becomes the next demon king he
will save gelda a woman whom zelgius
loves and a woman who was sealed away by
the demons because she is a vampire and
a vampire clan betrayed the demon clan
during the previous holy war in fact
zelgius was ordered to execute the
entire demon clan including gelda but he
couldn't bring himself to do it so he
sealed him away instead but in Chapter
300 the demon king in an adult
melioidosis body reveals that he was
never planning on allowing a traitor
like Mele Otis to inherit the throne he
also reveals that absorbing all 10
commandments will not only make you
stronger but it will also turn you into
a vessel for the demon king so it seems
that from the very beginning from the
day that the 10 commandments were
created the demon king had a back-up
plan
even if someone became powerful enough
to absorb all 10 commandments that
person still couldn't actually challenge
the demon king because they would merely
become a new vessel for him I'm wonder
if the curse that the demon king
bestowed on me leotis was all part of
his ultimate master plan the curse
served as motivation to force my leotis
to keep getting stronger in order to one
day save Elizabeth and all of this just
led meliodas to become an extremely
powerful vessel for the demon king a
vessel that is younger than the king's
old body and a vessel that is not bound
to stay in purgatory the demon king even
says that the reason he decided to take
over Mele Otis's body is because he
didn't want meliodas to waste his true
potential which implies that meliodas as
the demon King's eldest son really is
special he has the potential to become
incredibly powerful and that is exactly
why the demon king wants meliodas to
become his vessel the demon king then
goes on to mock Elizabeth telling her
that he will indeed break her curse just
like no Liotta's dreamed of doing for
thousands of years but he will only do
so that he can then go on and kill her
in the most brutal way possible this
again shows how much the demon king
still hates Elizabeth and how angry he
still is that meliodas decided to betray
the demon clan because of her however
during this exchange with Elizabeth the
demon king does betray one interesting
piece of information he says that he
wonders what meliodas face will look
like when he sees Elizabeth's corpse he
wonders if meliodas will become so
depressed that he will join Elizabeth in
the afterlife or whether he will simply
be relieved that he finally doesn't have
to worry about Elizabeth anymore the
very fact that the demon king is
wondering what meliodas will say when he
sees Elizabeth dead implies that the
demon Kings control of melioidosis body
may not be permanent if the demon king
knew that he could completely control
melioidosis body forever
then meliodas would never have the
chance to react to what happened to
Elizabeth since he would just be in the
demon King's complete control the demon
King's words here implied that meliodas
is still in there somewhere that he
might even be conscious and that it may
be possible for him to emerge once more
and take control of his own body I mean
let's face it the story would be pretty
anticlimactic if the demon king simply
remained in control and we never saw the
real malleolus again so I'm sure that
the story will go in a direction
normally ODIs regains control somehow if
you have any ideas about how exactly
this might happen feel free to let me
know
I think the malleolus is emotions that
fought the demon king together with bond
and wild back in purgatory we'll
probably play a crucial role in allowing
meliodas to regain control of himself by
the way I have to mention that in
Chapter 300 we witnessed the demon king
displaying some unbelievable power he is
able to take on Merlyn King Dee Ann
Elizabeth Miele and Ludo Chell on his
own without any problems
and yes Hendrickson was there too I
guess and the demon king is even able to
destroy Merlin's perfect cube a secret
technique that originates from the demon
realm within seconds honestly the demon
king is certainly a worthy final boss
and by the way massive props to Hawke
for his bravery in this chapter Hawke
tried to distract the demon king by
provoking him in the hopes of saving
Elizabeth but as I mentioned the demon
king simply destroys the perfect two
that was protecting hawk and nearly
kills him finally at the last second
bond finally shows up and grabs hawk and
the chapter ends as bond confronts this
new demon king possessed Mele Otis
oh man after all this time it looks like
we are finally going to see bond in
action after he spent decades in
purgatory getting stronger but we have
to also remember that bond may no longer
be immortal because in a previous
chapter he seemingly gave up his
immortality in order to save Elaine's
life I expect that in the coming
chapters we're going to see bond
attempting to wake meliodas up and get
him to take control of his own body once
again we will also see bond showcasing
his new power up of course and I predict
that we haven't seen the last of the
great Oh pink
the mighty captain of scraps disposal
himself in this chapter the demon king
repeatedly says that hawk is a rare
beast and we know that Hawk is actually
a creature from purgatory a creature
that the demon king specifically picked
to send out of purgatory in order to
keep an eye on meliodas
so I believe that Hawk is still going to
play some surprising role in the future
and of course the fact that his momma
turned out to be the mother of chaos may
also come into play but let me know what
you guys think do you agree that the
demon king has had this master plan to
take possession of Melissa's body for
thousands of years and that he planned
it all out very meticulously including
tempting Mele Otis with the idea of
becoming the next demon king in order to
break Elizabeth's curse setting up the
Ten Commandments as a trap formerly Otis
and even using hawk to keep a constant
eye on how meliodas was progressing what
do you think is going to happen next in
the story and is the demon king in
melioidosis body going to be the final
boss or are we still going to see the
seven deadly sins taking on the demon
king and maybe even the supreme deity in
their original bodies let me know down
in the comments if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins videos on this channel you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
also don't forget to follow us on Twitch
which TV slash anime uproar and join us
for the chapter 300 discussion and Q&A
live on Wednesday February 13th at 5
p.m. yes
I will be talking about the chapter and
taking your questions live and if we get
a good turnout we might start doing this
every week on our twitch channel link in
the description a big thank you to the
yahiko Darkover on deviant art for
allowing me to feature his art in this
video he is very talented be sure to
check him out link in the description as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]